[Music]
i paid more last week to put my car up
than i've paid in over two years cause
75 dollars for one fill up i paid 60
bucks to fill out my tank yesterday
that's a little too much yeah my bus i
drive gets about five miles a gallon
so i might not be going
we're gonna go anywhere
can't do much right now
russia's possible
[Music]
my reaction to that is there has to be
reserves here in the states that they
could release more
that's a bunch of bull well i just don't
understand why you had to shut the
pipeline down when we have potential to
take care of some of our own needs
rather than go
foreign with all of our needs well i
wonder if he actually discussed this
issue with the people who are actually
in charge of the
drilling and
producing oil so i think we need a
better answer than that you can't go
electric overnight i mean people can't
afford to buy a car every year or or
even the price of the cars you've got to
have what you have and take care of your
business now so we need all now it's
too much too soon we're not ready for it
no it has it has been going for some
time now
like inflation it's not something
that happened a couple of weeks it's
just going to go downhill if you want to
travel things has to change please
[Music]